bonjour nicolas bonjour magali bon merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
sur arte france évidemment plus de 150
journalistes qui ont signé une tribune
dans le blog mediapart appelant je cite
à combattre et à un
visibiliser eric zemmour en prévision de
la campagne présidentielle qu'en
pensez-vous nicolas bien cette tribu est
un exemple éclatant que cette campagne
présidentielle va être d'une violence
inouïe et il y à fort à parier que les
prochains mois seront des barils de tnt
médiatique en gros ça va saigner pour
tout le monde et à tous les étages alors
moi en lisant cette tribune cela m'a
fait penser à un entre-deux tours
appelées vous entre chirac et le pen en
2002 ou un célèbre animateur télé avait
lancé à ses centaines de millions de
téléspectateurs en fin d'émission votez
bien tout était dit votez bien nous
n'avions pas eu besoin de décodeur pour
savoir où se trouvait lempire du bien
l'expression chère à philippe le ray il
y avait eu aussi un le sociologue
rappelez-vous geoffroy de lagasnerie qui
avait assumé plus récemment c'est en
septembre 2020 sur france inter vous
savez cet olympe e public du pluralisme
des voix une certaine forme de censure
contre les idées qu'ils jugent d'extrême
droite et délirante et là c'est à peu
près la même chose avec ses 150 joyeuse
qui invite je cite à combattre il ya un
visibiliser 1 je suis nouveau les
personnes prenant des idées fascistes
racistes et xénophobes sexistes
homophobes et négationniste fin de
citation durant cette campagne
présidentielle à venir alors on notera
que ça fait beaucoup de choses horribles
à forte pour un seul homme ou pour une
seule femme puisque personne et
nominativement visant cette tribune mais
la cible n'est pas facile difficile
pendant identifier cependant cette
initiative pose bien des questions de
fond sur l'avenir du débat en france et
plus largement sur l'opinion que les
médias mainstream et certains
journalistes se font des français magali
alors selon vous est ce qu'il y a refus
du débat ou carrément orientations du
débat ben oui il clairement une volonté
de faire taire les personnalités qui ne
colle pas la doxa dominante et à la
pensée unique car la volonté
d'ostraciser a pris le pas sur la bonne
vieille méthode de la délégitimation
et ce matin le sujet n'est clairement
pas de défendre exe mourou d'encenser
jean luc mélenchon ou de faire une
homélie écolo pour yannick jadot cela
nécessite de prendre la hauteur et aller
autant qu'on le peut au fond des choses
et le fond des choses c'est quoi avec ça
mais n'exerce dans un premier temps une
admirable couardise intellectuelle à ne
plus vouloir débattre en somme vous
n'avez aucun argument à donner face à
des idées qui vous sont opposés en tout
point et vous êtes et que vous estimez
détestable alors alors quoi vous
préférez dézinguer demandé une
obligation à quitter le territoire
médiatique sur le champ nous voilà
désormais à l'arrivée arrivée pardon à
l'air de l'occulté f délivré par l'
empire du bien gouverné par les mêmes
personnes qui ont de la démocratie par
la bouche et qui s'essuie les lèvres
qu'une serviette de bons sentiments car
l'affrontement dans ce pays si le combat
des idées et ceux qui n'y sont pas prêts
vous devrez utiliser des méthodes
expéditives diamétralement opposées de
ce qui a fait la vie des idées dans ce
pays et puis vous avez quelque chose de
beaucoup plus pernicieuse cette couche
de prétendus bons sentiments à la
génoise d'humanisme lorsque vous grattez
derrière ce raisonnement de faire
barrage à la haine au racisme la
xénophobie au populisme nationalisme et
que sais-je encore vous déclarez vous
découvre qu'en réalité qui est mise en
cause qui est soupçonné de se laisser
aller à des penchants détestable et à
des idées nauséabondes qui pourrait se
faire complice de la pire des idéologies
et bien ce sont les millions de français
qui sont directement visés par cette
rhétorique en réalité avec ses
raisonnements en laissant entendre que
ces mêmes français sont trop bêtes pour
ne pas faire la part des choses et
laisser parler leur intelligence ils
seraient trop stupides pour ne pas voir
le péril qui les guette et donc
incapable de réfléchir sereinement c'est
avec cette même ordre que les gilets
jaunes ont été médiatiquement brisée
pendant de longues semaines en les
faisant passer vous le savez pour des
idiots de la start up nation incapables
de voir la flamboyante intelligence du
petit père des peuples qui lui était en
marche à la haye la tribune laissent
entendre qu'eric zemmour est en sommes
gonflés par les médias et que c'est
grâce à cette visibilité que ces idées
se répandront n'avait connu ça avec le
rassemblement national
oui mais voilà une nouvelle erreur
idéologique voilà un poncif facile à
apprendre et à recracher et qui exonère
surtout ses opposants de réfléchir car
l'idéologie est un outil facile pour
ceux qui n'ont plus rien à penser pour
nous journalistes cela demande beaucoup
de travail pour comprendre la
trajectoire que prend ce pays sous
l'impulsion d'une partie de son peuple
et de quoi eric zemmour est le symptôme
qu'on le déplore ou pas seul un débat
public équitable proposer aux français
peut leur permettre d'envoyer au cachot
de l'histoire de france une personnalité
des idées qu'il ne partage pas mais tout
cela se joue dans les urnes et ce sont
aux français d'en décider et à personne
d'autre victor hugo écrivait que je cite
rien n'arrête une idée dont le temps est
venu alors si alors si peut-être en
tentant de comprendre la cause et d'y
apporter la contradiction mais
certainement pas l'excommunication et la
condamnation qui ne qui n'est qu'un coup
d'épée dans l'eau croupie des bons
sentiments et l'avenir de ce pays est
une affaire trop sérieuse pour s'y
vautrer et vouloir faire taire exe moore
qu'on partage ou qu'on condamne
fortement ses idées participe à vouloir
liquider ce qu'il reste de démocratie et
de notre liberté d'expression le boycott
c'est jamais bon merci beaucoup nicolas
vidal à merci c'était l'édito politique
de la matinale de rtl france